welcome back to the wildlife podcast i'm
james marshall and this episode
is brought to you by the great straight
face razors
if you live in new zealand and you're
after a new razor then look no further
than this great product
the sharpest five blade head will have
your face
looking like a fresh young lad again and
for what led listeners
you can get a whopping fifty percent off
your first order
by heading to wadala.com and clicking on
the straight face
logo and the discount will be all there
ready to go
fifteen dollars for four heads it's an
absolute steal and i must try if you're
looking for a new razer
also a massive thank you to anyone who
has brought themselves some lad merch
or some water lead coffee or some pure
sport cbd
all of these things have helped bring
this podcast to you so if you enjoy this
podcast head over to waterlab.com
and treat yourself to one of these great
products it is all very much appreciated
and it is helping make this podcast grow
anyway let's get into this one let's
roll the intro
[Music]
i just love that love that tune now
today i have a very special guest on the
podcast
after the rugby world was shocked last
week with the sudden retirement of one
of
english premiership's most promising
young players due to concussion
at just a tender age of 24 years old i
thought it was a great chance to get the
lad on
to reflect about his career and go into
some depth about concussion
and like all my guests are this guy is
an absolute lad
one of the greats it is theo brophy
clues welcome boris thanks for coming on
mate
hey jimmy thanks for having me mate mate
so it's all done rugby
is finished how do you feel yeah i feel
uh i feel old to be honest i feel older
than i yeah
i thought i would i'm joining joining
the retired crew
so um yeah i mean yeah thanks it's uh
it's really like i mean there's lots to
be uh really positive about in terms of
like
how much i enjoyed my career and
obviously i've got a few exciting things
to look forward to but it is a bit of a
weird feeling
um definitely was it a sudden incident i
didn't know it was coming at all so it
sort of shocked me but did you sort of
have a feeling
it was close or how did it all happen so
like obviously like as you as you'll
know but i guess people listen to my
life
i've had a decent history of concussions
so i've had
obviously a few kind of normal ones and
a couple of bad ones i end up taking a
um a layoff kind of a forced layoff for
about
six months um probably two two and a bit
three years ago
um but since then i'd been fine really
so like i'd had no issues with my head
so i was kind of fit and played kind of
two seasons
and then i basically had one um probably
kind of two months ago and then played a
good run of games after that and then
had another one
and um so it was kind of like it was
fine i had no issues and then suddenly
it was kind of in a picture again and um
i had a pretty
open conversation with bruiser the head
of medical um
irish and um after this kind of last
concussion
he basically sat down i kind of walked
into the physio room and i was kind of
like
i'd obviously thought about my career
before and thought about concussion art
because of
my history with it and um but yeah it
was quite interesting him sitting me
down and
looking me in the eyes and him kind of
started to tear up and i was like what's
he gonna say here
um and he was just like look i didn't
think yeah i was just like
he said to me that he'd been thinking
about it a lot and obviously he'd known
me ever since i've been in the club so
he'd known me
like since i was 17. yeah and he kind of
looks at me as like
look there like i think i think you're
done here i think it's time like for my
kind of
well-being and my kind of my health
going forward he was like i don't think
he can keep doing this
um i genuinely believe like this is the
right thing to do and i kind of sat
there and looked at him and was like
wow that just happened um so
yeah after that it was um we had a kind
of a few more conversations with like a
concussion clinic the specialists
but i think when he told me that
obviously it had been in my head i kind
of looked at him and because i like
i trust him so much i was just like you
know what he's right this is the best
thing so
that was it really mate so it was kind
of like in a way it was crazy
it was a long time coming but also it
then happened very very quickly
yeah so going into that meeting you had
no no thoughts at all about retirement
not really like i'd probably like it's
probably worth mentioning that probably
a few months before so before
my kind of first concussion this season
i've had i had a chat with um
because there's a lot of stuff coming
out in england i don't know kind of
how how far it's spanning in terms of
rugby but there's a few kind of ex-rugby
players have you heard about this
their lawsuit yeah so there's a couple
of
england and welsh probably players suing
the rfu for kind of mismanagement of
concussions because
sadly they've got early onset dementia
um
due to rugby injuries which is which is
awful but
i'd kind of that had come out before
this happened so i've had a few
conversations because obviously
having had a couple myself i was a bit
worried but i was kind of
not kind of like talked down but there's
there's lots of factors mitigating
factors and there's
so complicated but um so i'd had a
conversation with it with a coach who'd
retired because of concussion
and he basically said to me that
he was 27 when he retired and he said to
me that like
i'd be absolutely fine if i was retired
as in like if i retired straight away
he was like i didn't want to push myself
till the absolute limit
but he was like you'll be absolutely
fine mate he's like just do it and i was
like i haven't
i haven't asked about if i should retire
or not and i've got a coach telling me
that i'm gonna be fired i was like
what's going on here so like i had it
framed in my mind
and then i guess potentially after the
concussion so
it was a friday night game against bath
literally
the first impact of the game kind of
rocked me and i felt pretty often it was
like two minutes or so like ball and
play and i got taken off after that
and it probably had like two two and a
bit days before i spoke to bruiser but
then yeah like
i hadn't really thought about it i
wasn't like this is it this is like the
last one
i was like oh i'll go speak to him see
what he has to say
and then yeah after that move pretty
quickly so that final one wasn't even a
massive
impact it was just a regular tackle yeah
i mean
i think this is the thing that kind of
worried brian is that like it was
it was literally off the kickoff i was
chasing and there was like a lifting pod
um like it's gone up and i've gone to
kind of hit it and
i think kind of like my like my chin
like neck area had been hit by someone
like
knee or something as they were coming
down yeah but it wasn't like i
got a shoulder to the head in like a
brutal tackle yeah and then
after that basically like brian like i
said he he's known me for a while so he
kind of knows when
i've had something he was watching me
straight after that
and then i had a couple and then i
actually got a decent shot on my head
and like a hip
in a tackle so it was it wasn't like a
super clear-cut one and i think he
from his experience and then obviously
had he had time to think about it um
there's obviously a few
kind of reasons behind the kind of
retirement it's not like
yeah don't know jumping ship and it like
to be honest it's not
it's not massively like my decision like
i don't i don't really want to retire
but
like i said when someone has that
conversation you are like i gotta take
it seriously
so what sort of symptoms do you have
from this one were they any different to
any of the other ones any worse no i
think something that i
probably struggle with this one a little
bit more was like balance like that one
even though it wasn't particularly bad
for a couple days after i felt i felt
really bad
yeah just kind of the general stuff like
balance dizziness headaches
and they probably lasted kind of um
probably like just over a week um but i
was kind of on my way to
making this decision by then um
i've not been someone who's like
struggled really long term with symptoms
but
i think brian and brian said well that
like
you don't want to get to the point here
when you can't do anything until you
make the call to stop hitting your head
um and i think the nature of my career
is that like i've had a few
i've had quite a few and he
believes and i i kind of he said it out
really well that was like it's not
really going to change and you don't
want to kind of
keep going down that road until you're
like oh my god we could have made this
decision a few years ago
yeah fair enough was there ever thought
of you just taking a long break out of
the game maybe like one or two years and
then reassess it then or
you just know like once once you're done
you you feel like you're done there's no
point trying to get back in there
it's a really good point and because
i've had a quite long
layoff that kind of actually kind of
worked in a way like i was kind of fine
after that i didn't i didn't struggle
with it so much
it kind of crossed my mind and then i
was like
you know what there is like there is
things i want to do outside of rugby
there is a life i want to pursue and
i i was it i think i was at this point
when i i had this conversation i think i
was took a week off and went to my mom
in wales and just kind of chilled out
for a bit
and um yeah it got to the point where i
was like i i don't
want to look back at this and be like i
should have done something different
um especially like i said with the the
medical advice i got i was like
and a lot of people said to me like
there was a lot of really good people
around me being like
there's like well rugby is brilliant
there's a lot more to life and like you
you know that you've got three boys now
and
i think obviously it gets quite like
serious when you're thinking about it so
long term
um and so i was just like you know what
i think that's me and i think
that i don't want to kind of get back in
and then have one really bad one it'll
be like honestly like what was i
thinking
like i kind of had those like
conversations so i think
while i would love to and while i'm kind
of going to realize how much i miss
being a rugby player
at some point in the next kind of few
months i just like
it would just kill me if i look back at
it and was like i made the wrong
decision
yeah so you're still with the boys at
the moment you're still in around the
environment
still as a professional rugby player
until the end of the season is that
right
yes that is right i'm like the captain
of the non-23
i'm kind of currently yeah i'm uh
yeah so i'm kind of doing bits and bobs
and training and i'm kind of jamming
with the boys being in meetings helping
out and um
obviously running around my pink beard
which the non-contact bib so
no one's laying a finger on me
thankfully um
which i've actually realized like
rugby's class when you don't have to
tackle or uh
or like do any contact in trading so
yeah but that's been like
i mean that's been really nice i think
that's kind of the easiest kind of
transition like i've been around all the
boys
i've been around my good mates and like
it was actually like
it was so nice mate to like tell them
like face to face like while obviously
the announcement kind of came out i'd
i'd spoken to the guys at the club
a couple of weeks previous and
it was it's pretty brutal standing up
for like after a team meeting and being
like look this is this is what's
happening but like it was really nice in
the way that i got to like
tell everyone like to their face like
exactly kind of what was happening and
why it was going on but
yeah mate and this period has been like
it's been a bit of a holiday i guess
like being around everyone still
training and still seeing the boys
outside of rugby
playing golf for them like yeah i know
and my body doesn't feel [ __ ] all the
time so that's good too
have you managed to avoid snaker than
those 15 or 15
run around he's he used to be a
nightmare in those games always after
the injured bibs
i know that's why he's called the snake
i mean he'll say that it's not why it's
called the snake
but it is really um i see i just see a
shiny dome flying at me
from uh from miles away now so i can get
out of the way
yeah it's um it is quite there is kind
of a funny way i'm like
i like if obviously kind of it's like a
square shoulder or whatever a boy's kind
of running towards me and i'll like
shout touch and then obviously like the
big boys like they just they've got no
idea
so i've got to the point where like i'm
like diving out of the way of tackles
it's kind of like it's a bit of a joke
but
um i've got to make the most of it while
i still can oh that's classic
so how many concussions did you actually
have all up and like what sort of number
are we talking here was it was it a mess
of number
so you ask someone who's had a few
concussions how many concussions they
have and they say i don't know
it's always yeah i think in my um
in my professional like career i
probably had
um six or seven kind of proper
incidences
um and like i've been lucky in the fact
that
i've got like a really good medical team
around me there's loads of regulations
um there's a specialist concussion
clinic that's like outside of the club
that we have to go see after concussions
to get a kind of unbiased view
yeah so i'd say all mine
have been managed pretty well and also
they'll say that it's not like
the amount of concussions it's like the
kind of it's the prolonged exposure to
like head impacts
so if you have like it's like you had a
20-year career
you're obviously exposed to quite a lot
of head impacts versus if you had
a six-year career like mine and had a
couple of serious ones
i mean yeah you'll speak to these guys
and i'll tell you they don't know but i
think there's
it's kind of you obviously hear some
like horrible numbers about people like
over 10
i'm always lucky in the situation that
it's kind of taking my heart out of my
hands
in a way yeah and what are your thoughts
on that lawsuit are you
you've obviously got no regrets about
playing rugby at all because yes
you've sort of walked away from the game
fine but how do you feel about these
guys who are um
looking to press charges against world
rage before um the way their head knocks
were treated
yeah it's difficult like i obviously
they like they played in kind of like a
different area to us so they're like
coming up through the kind of like just
as it's turning professional
like you hear like horror stories about
the stuff they go through in training
and boys getting knocked out in training
and then playing the next day
and like all stuff like this and also as
well like something that like i'm quite
clear about like obviously quite a few
people have messaged me after
the announcement and stuff i don't have
anything against rugby
and i'm i'm glad that i don't and i'm
not bitter about anything about stuff
was managed or whatever
because like it's kind of just this
what's happened to me it's not rugby's
in general whereas i think these guys
have had such
like severe kind of life-changing
alterations that i think
they would view in a very different way
especially with some of the things they
probably had to go through
with anything i don't know the ins and
outs of it but i think um
i think they do want to change the sport
as well like i think they do want to
make sure that it's
that the league and the unions are doing
everything they can which i think is
good
um and there's obviously a lot of chat
around contact and training and
hias and stuff so i think like things
like this will hopefully change the game
for the better
not that i think there is some inherent
real issue
with uh with rugby because it's a
contact sport
and injuries happen right you know and
what are your thoughts about the rules
at the moment obviously i think it's a
little bit worse over in the
english premiership and over in the uk
around the
head knocks and red cards and i've seen
some pretty rough calls on some guys
with
accidental head contact so how do you
feel the gamers over there do you think
they're
they're on the money with going
overboard with the decisions or
do you think it might be a little bit of
an overreaction
yeah i mean i'd hate to be a ref or on
the refereeing board at the moment
because like you said there is yeah and
like they're obviously
like they are trying and they they have
to look after players but
it's really difficult some of the rules
that are being made because
like we've had a couple this year where
in tackles players
are kind of they've they've ducked and
you know like i mean you watch forwards
like
they they just hit heads like it happens
like and
and they're getting red cards and
tackles where there's no malice there's
no intent like people just hit heads
yeah like it's um like i was chatting
um with a couple of boys watching the
game last night about the fact that
teams like are gonna just start waiting
to till there's 14 men on the pitch to
start like
playing because i don't know i don't
know what the stats are but every game
someone's getting yellow carded or red
carded for
high tackle or impact to the head yeah
i'm lucky that i've only ever like
chopped people loads i'm not big enough
to whack people high
so if i was a big boy you like like
hitting people it would be tough um
i think it's good that they're trying to
go overboard in terms of
they're trying to change the way that
players are tackling yeah
but the problem is i don't think i don't
think they'll achieve that by
like penalizing people i think you need
to like coach people how to tackle
differently
yeah um i don't know i don't think you
were still at the club when they
our second round in the champ no when um
we had uh they had this thing called the
championship cup
and they thought they were going to
change the rules so basically you
couldn't tackle like anything above like
the nipples was like a high tackle
yeah and genuinely so
everyone was like chop tackling first
game six concussions
was it like genuinely so because they
just changed the rules
like players like all of a sudden like
were doing stuff they'd never done
before
um like diving at people's ankles people
just getting like head-on hips like
those knees
like it was just like it was a bit it's
a bit of a sick joke like really
watching this happen like the first game
um so i don't think you'll end up
changing it too much from like
setting obviously you do have to set
some rules and
and kind of penalize players who do it
badly but i think trying to coach
players to do it safer and
i don't know how you'd enforce that but
basically especially from a young age
coaching people to tackle
and carry in a way that doesn't lead to
as many head impacts is probably the way
to go yeah that's an interesting one so
did you get more
head knocks from actually tackling or
carrying the ball because i always felt
like whenever i got a head high it
didn't really affect the head my
my main head knocks and incidents were
all from
trying to tackle low and getting a hip
or getting an elbow or a knee or
something like that
but um any sort of head higher god i
always felt like i could just sort of
bounce up and it was
it wasn't too bad but i don't know what
was what was your experience like
exactly the same i used to be like
obviously like i wasn't a big guy
like the only way i could attack me was
like just like attacking a load chop
tackling getting low
even like maybe you'll have it whether
like the dreaded like the
massive number eight picks and just
charges at you like the only thing you
can do
is dive at their feet like yeah um or
you or you'll get on their highlight
reel
so that's what i chose
yeah i'll take the highlight reel every
day um
yeah it was um yeah i they are exactly
the same
so i was always tackling low and i
would i'd say like pretty much all of my
concussions would be from
tackling low around people's knees hips
everything like that
i don't like i like tackling but i was
pretty rubbish at it so i would just
like throw myself at people
and like i genuinely watched some of the
like some of my tackles and like
deck danaher like hang his head like his
hands in his
his arms watching me try to tackle
people just throwing myself um but like
yeah i i would like i'll get hit around
the head and like you're kind of fine
but then you get like a tackle and your
head glances the hip and you get a
concussion it's um yeah
i've actually probably in the last two
years just like our defense coast
coach changing and he wanted us to
hold the ball up basically get time in
the tackle and tackle people higher
get our chests in front and like that's
just the way he coached it
and i suddenly i mean this coincided
with me
coming back from having a bit of time
off um
but i felt like straight away i wasn't
getting concussions or i wasn't i wasn't
feeling like my face was getting
messed up yeah like playing rugby so i
like it's a weird one i would say that
like for me in my experience like
tackling higher
was was better for my head um obviously
i was a bit stronger probably so yeah i
have the same
same experience as you really it's
interesting and it's one for i guess
world rugby and stuff to
really look into because yeah i i feel
like
the trying to lower the tackle height
all kind of makes it more dangerous like
you obviously experienced in that um and
that
rule trial six concussions in the first
day
that's loose they they scrapped it yeah
they scrapped it after the
the first four rounds they were like we
can't keep doing this
which is i mean obviously like we're
laughing at it it's pretty serious but
it was like
what's going on because you did just get
players who never before like diving at
people
and obviously they're gonna get need in
the head if they don't know how to do
that
yeah so you're right i think it's i
don't know if you can lead it from
rugby but i mean like you know that
anything like it takes a long time for
these things to change
and so like trying to teach people to
tackle them in a different way i mean
maybe the whole concu the whole like
conversation about concussion like
you'll speak to
i'll speak to the neurologist and he's
like i don't know
i don't know how to make it better which
is kind of scary really it's a bit like
you're sitting there listening to this
guy and he's like the expert
and he's like yeah we just don't know
really like we just and
he's being completely honest because
he's not going to lie to you and say
that
they know exactly what it causes and how
to reduce it but yeah
it is an ongoing kind of learning thing
for rugby as a sport
but like when you say about tackle
height you watch something like the um
the nrl stuff at the moment is pretty
savage with some of those that are going
on
mate they're struggling to keep their
tackles low at the moment they're
getting
at least two or three in the bin every
game
they're struggling to adapt yeah
definitely
anyway mate it's all been awesome to
hear how the sort of journey finished
but let's go back to the start for you
like
um obviously a very promising young
player how did your rugby career sort of
start
yeah i had a pretty kind of straight
line for the first couple of years
um it was i kind of like at school i had
a really good school team and a really
good school coach so i started i
actually started irish mate when i was
when i was 12
which seems like a long time ago yeah
so i ended up so i was at i was i played
my like junior rugby at newbury
um and then kind of got involved in
berkshire kind of county's setup and
then
through that kind of got into the irish
setup
and so yeah i was training at the
training ground since i was 12 or kind
of like wednesday nights
um is 12 normal or
i don't know i don't think so i i was
turning 13 but i was still 12 at the
time
yeah like it does sound very early it's
my first year county so like i literally
was training with like
16 year olds um which i
which i'd say to be fair like as a
younger player like i think that's
why i kind of developed as a player
because i was always playing with boys
that are older than me like i don't know
how the kind of different systems work
in different countries but
i'm like literally as kind of young as i
remember i was always playing with older
players yeah
um so i was irish kind of in there like
silver academy
i think they call it um and pretty much
just obviously kind of went through that
while i was playing at school
i then had kind of some good experience
with the england age grade system so i
kind of got into that through the irish
academy
um and some of like coaches like there
were like
incredible um john fletcher is like a
coach that i still speak to and he's
like he ran the
england age grades for years and years
um and like some of the best players
going to england golden age of like
farrell the toejay um the van of polars
and stuff like we're still coached by
him and so
to get into that pathway was pretty it
was pretty cool
um and then pretty much from work from
when i left school i got
got signed full time from irish and then
kind of got into it from there i think
there's
then it kind of well that was pretty
linear it then kind of
hit the rocks a little bit went very up
and down for a few years but it was um
it was a pretty ideal start
to my rugby career yeah man how good is
that and what age were you when you made
your
irish debut i was 17 so um
still at school yeah it was um i got i
got a train straight from school
um and i didn't i didn't know maca at
the time but you'll know maca he kind of
he kind of greeted me um on the train
and
and got me in the cab to we were playing
against scarlett so um
yeah that was a pretty it was pretty
surreal i played three games while
while i was still um in my last year at
school a couple of um
lv cup games which obviously like a
younger competition typically yeah
but yeah that first game was pretty
pretty unreal
like i was on the bench obviously and it
snowed the whole game so like i'm 17
like coming on i cannot feel my hands
like properly [ __ ] it so
it was um yeah it was class but it was
um pretty surreal experience
it was it you at 10 then too yeah so um
i literally got i got five minutes i
scored with my second touch i literally
got past the ball
over the line and i was just like yeah i
know
i was just like this is incredible um
but
yeah it was like like it was like
different level obviously like i was a
kid
um i genuinely still to this day don't
think i knew
many of the calls i was just kind of
like shouting as loud as i could to try
and seem like i knew what was going on
as a lot of young tens can probably
imagine the young boys when they come
through are just like
shouting because they're like trying to
seem like they know what's going on yeah
well it's always an intimidating place
to
like especially at that age to try and
drive a team around like 17 years old
must have been
pretty intimidating but you're a
confident sort of bloke and were you
always like that
even at that age i probably like
i wasn't naturally like a super
confident guy but i had that thing when
i played rugby
like i kind of i just kind of came out
my shell a little bit yeah
um i probably went like i said i was
gonna say overboard but like
you know you're trying to overcompensate
when you feel like you're not that
comfortable in a situation yeah
and trying to like seem like you're more
confident i think i probably had that
one
when i was kind of coming through um i
was also like i mean
you you probably kind of saw it over
this of this that i was so like
like rugby was like my life um
when i was like i mean growing up but
obviously like 18 19
it was like i was just obsessed with
rugby like proper kind of
proper rugby noise like just loved it so
i i mean i think that like helped me
get into it but i think it kind of also
probably didn't help me in a little in a
few ways as well
what ways do you think it didn't help
you i don't think i was a particularly
like approachable guy when i was kind of
like 18 19 like i don't know obviously i
had a few kind of
injuries at the time so i didn't like my
first season i played a decent bit of
rugby
and then in the next two years obviously
like injury kind of like
i like struck i guess i had a few kind
of bigger ones but
i think um i struggled to kind of really
build like really good relationships
with people in the team because i was
kind of just like rugby and then i'd go
home and do my own thing
um especially like even like the boys
around me at my age i was probably like
a little kind of unwelcoming and pretty
just like serious and straightforward
being like
like you know like and like you're like
the king of this is like some of the
best rugby players just like
just super good guys like really
friendly like
good at building relationships and just
have a good time while they're doing it
and i probably kind of missed out on
that kind of enjoyment
and kind of like social aspect when i
was a little bit younger because i was a
bit
because i was very straight down the
line of focus about what i was trying to
do
that's interesting to hear so do you
think that was because of your
personality type or because
um you were just so obsessed with
becoming the best rugby player you could
be
it was it was probably like a bit of my
personality like i wasn't actually quite
like analytical and kind of like
like the detail side of it um i like
being specific with stuff but then i
think obviously the kind of
like the pressure of like trying to kind
of get into a premiership side and
and also like premiership rugby as i
found out like i came from a
like eighth grade system where it was
very like
decision making and very loose and very
unstructured and i really liked
that i've kind of thrived off that and
then i suddenly got put in environment
when i had to tell
14 guys around me where they should be
for the next like four phases in a row
yeah
and i think that kind of just like
brought out the kind of analytical
planning side of me
that then probably didn't help me like
develop as a player because i was just
focused on telling people around them
too and
where they were going to be rather than
just like playing rugby and playing the
game
um so i think it kind of brought out in
me um but then obviously like you said
you get older have some more experiences
and
things change a little yeah but you
obviously made the england
and the 20s two years in a row didn't
yeah so how was that experience
yeah it was uh it was great and also
like really really [ __ ] at the same time
um it was like my first year i played a
decent bit of premiership rugby and
didn't play that six nations and then
kind of rocked up to the
um it was the manchester world cup 20s
yeah and
we ended up going to win that but i i
got injured in the first game i
tore a ligam in my foot quite badly in
in the first game and so
didn't like feel like i was a like a
part of that team even though i kind of
was
and then watching him go on to win it
was like was brilliant i didn't really
have any bitterness but i
i wasn't involved in the team that won
it and so
the kind of the next year rolled around
and i was like i was back fair and i was
like yeah this is going to be great this
is kind of
my time to have a good crack and then
the six nations
that year was kind of i was gearing up
for it and then had a bit of a niggly
another niggly injury so i end up
playing the last two games but i
probably
played about 15 minutes of rugby in that
six nations um
but we wanna we won a grand slam um in
ireland on st
patrick's day which was like up there in
terms of like class memories
um my dad had been there all day
as an in ireland in dublin and he like
could not speak by the time
he got to the end of the game and so i
could come up to it i'm like come on
like where have i met a laughter
and he just gives this like weird
semblance of just like
shouting at me i'm like he's got no idea
where he is
i still don't think he remembers that
day
which is quite funny
those injuries were there head knocks or
were they something else something else
yeah so like like thankfully like i
haven't had like
loads and loads and loads so i've also
had loads of other injuries as well
which has given my head
a head a bit of a rest um which is funny
so yeah they were like they were they
were both feet and then
yeah so that then it got to the the
second world cup i played in
um which was brilliant and it was kind
of more my like age group and
we got to the final that year and then
got got absolutely battered by uh
the the the all blacks um that kind of
that crew
well i did anything so i got injured in
the semi-final again sadly
the same injury i've done the year
before on my other foot so
that's what i mean in terms of the like
it was brilliant like the experiences i
had and
like the boys that we kind of came
through and played with was
was brilliant and really special but
yeah i had some uh some pretty kind of
testing times
that was kind of my my main struggles
with her injury
were around that time but yeah it was
something like there's some class
memories and
like so being on tour when you're like
18 19 like for a long period of time
it's kind of like
it's just like a real experience like
it's unbelievable
yeah and how did you deal with your
injuries like you had so many throughout
your career like how did you did you
come up with a process to deal with them
or especially at a young age
and big sort of world cups like that
must have been hard to sort of
deal with mentally yeah i like the first
one like really hit me like i mentioned
like my kind of getting into rugby was
pretty straightforward
in terms of like it was like academy
system age grade system
like first team at irish and
and then that first injury here and it
kind of like i mentioned about those
like things about me just being a rugby
player and like having not much else in
my life or just being
kind of too focused on that kind of came
became
pretty apparent in terms of i really
struggled to kind of deal with life and
i was just like
this sucks i was kind of annoyed and
angry lots but then
you'll know mate that like sometimes
like the really like rubbish types of
injury end up
they teach you a lot and you end up
becoming a better player and a better
person because of it so i think i
i got to experience that firsthand like
every the second time
i did that same foot injury like it
sucked for like immediately but then
i learned to kind of get on with stuff
very quickly and i learned to
focus on what i could actually do rather
than just being like life's unfair this
sucks
and i think each time i got injured i
kind of
learned to do that more and also it gave
me more time outside of rugby to develop
different things i was interested in to
study um
to do other things and i think that even
when i look back at my career and
the injuries i had i still think they
they really helped me as a person
um which i think a lot of people would
speak to and
say and i think that's kind of one of
the good things and the bad things about
being injured yeah i think that's a
great point because every rugby player
gets injured at some point throughout
their career and
how they sort of deal with it and bounce
back
there's a massive turning point in a lot
of guy's career some guys don't seem to
bounce back quite like they did
from their first injury and i guess
that's just the mindset they take into
that rehab and
as to how they sort of come back and
present themselves as a player when
they're ready to go
so it's a really good point that you
make there yeah and like
you look at some players that like are
still playing like
i don't i don't i actually know he's
trolled injuries i i don't know him
particularly well but like you look at
like james o'connor
as someone who had i mean loads of stuff
like
playing for the wallabies like really
young and then had injuries and issues
with like selection and fitness and like
off-field stuff i guess
i don't know his whole story but and now
he's being considered
being like potentially being the captain
for the wallabies like people like him
and there'll be loads of boys that
have done this at like a high level that
have shown that real life flexibility
and like i genuinely think that's one of
the most
impressive things about people who have
long careers but careers that
they do so well but also have some like
really big injuries
um like like you've obviously had your
fair share as well and like
you'll you'll know how difficult it is
to come back but i think once you
experience
getting back once you can kind of do it
again
yeah for sure there's some guys who just
get a tough break when it comes to
injuries there
yeah so you played 63 caps for london
irish obviously
quite a decent amount of games in the
end
any um games that sort of stand out for
you this season
um a bit of a run we've had and like
it's kind of
the first time well not the first time
but kind of one of the main time i felt
like a real part
part of the team we've we kind of had a
few like
ridiculous games like we had we were
losing like 32-3 against bristol
who were the the league leaders still
are like playing an unbelievable brand
of rugby
and coming back and drawing that game um
was pretty cool
um we had a a quarter not a quarter
final like around a 16
european game against cardiff this year
we had a red card with about 30 minutes
to play
um ended up winning in the last minute
we scored three tries in the last five
minutes to come back and win that game
yeah that was pretty cool um
i've had like i think my first and
patrick's day game like you obviously
been at the club you'll know that like
some paddy's day is quite a big thing
for irish and so playing against
gloucester
a while back um a few years ago european
and and scoring a try and that i think
that was quite a big moment for me
because like i'd been at the club for
ages but i've never played this in
patrick's day game
and that was pretty sick and i remember
like as much as that try was cool like i
remember i got
like a part of guinness chucked on my
head at the end of the game
and so like that was like my overriding
memory from that game
and i was like yeah this is what it's
supposed to be like
oh yeah you talked about the season um
having a big
impact on the side this season you're
traditionally a 10 but you got moved to
12 this season how did that sort of come
about
yeah i i basically became the um like
proper utility back this year
we had like i think we had like because
of injuries and like i ended up coming
off the bench and playing lots of
different positions
um i'd actually played 12 a little bit
kind of three minor 20s
and kind of like on and off i'd played i
played a bit 12 and i was obviously that
kind of
that 12 that was going to move the ball
like as a flight half like going to move
the ball around could kick
um could do all those things and
i think because of like the squad that
we had at the time paddy at 10
irish is like this he's kind of just
like he runs the team like the team is
kind of his he
he can he controls everything and he's
been a brilliant player for us this year
and so like it never like i probably
wasn't going to play much at 10
and so because of an injury and some
like selection stuff i ended up starting
the game at 12
um and that was that bristol game
actually where we were losing by 30
points
after half time and i think like just
for me at that time like
i got to a point in my career i was like
i'm not going to hold back and i'm going
to try stuff and
and take risks which i probably hadn't
done before and i think because of that
it like it led itself to a few things
coming off and i actually just really
enjoyed playing
playing 12 having a bit more space kind
of being that second set of eyes second
set of hands
i think briefly i remember i think we
played 10 and 12 against twins a lot
a few years ago and like i just think
like you get to play inside like playing
outside you was like a good experience
because you kind of
get to like also like learn off that
person but kind of help them and help
them manage the team as someone who's
played by half as well yeah
um and so i think it just it kind of
suited me this year
in the team that we were we had i've
always found tens love having another 10
playing 12 outside them because
second ball player they they know what
to look for they know the comms to feed
and
it just makes their job so much easier
yeah it literally is
i think those be fair you can you can
overdo it we've had a couple of times
this season where we've had like
we spoke about jacob and like we've had
like three or four tens on the pitch at
the same time playing different
positions
and i'm like that's a bit much because
at some point someone needs to make a
tackle
but no it is like you said it's good and
it kind of takes the pressure off that
guy he's actually playing 10 and then
as a 10 playing 12 you can actually just
have a bit more freedom you don't have
to run the team
as much you don't have to make as many
decisions
like i mentioned like i end up just just
playing rugby and playing
playing the game as opposed to like
thinking about stuff and controlling
other people
mate sounds like you were just ready to
take off and then
crack onto the international scene but
uh
injuries cut it short but obviously it's
awesome to hear that you're comfortable
with that
and um that you're in a good space
obviously not being affected by
too much your body anyway
but life after rugby you're into that
now or you're into that soon
once the season's finished uh what are
your plans i know you've set up an
awesome
nutrition plan called the rugby grab do
you want to talk about that
yeah so that's one of those things that
kind of outside of rugby
i had that time to kind of try and do
something and so me and harry ellington
who's irish as well
we um we basically got like forced to
because the boys at the club basically
are we had an old snc coach who
basically didn't trust anyone to cook
any meals for themselves so he asked me
and harry to like set up a uh
a recipe sharing platform for the club
so people would
cook properly outside of uh outside of
the club and so from that it kind of
like snowballed i guess like kind of
accidentally into us setting up this
this page of rugby crub
and um it basically became like our kind
of our life
kind of our job for a couple years
outside of rugby we basically were
putting recipes we both actually did a
nutrition qualification
outside it as well so yeah rugby grab it
became this we were doing some coaching
as well
and um it's uh it was really good fun to
be fair and like
i mentioned to you earlier we're kind of
we're looking for someone at the moment
to kind of help us come on board and do
some more content for us while our both
our lives are changing a little bit so
um it's been a brilliant journey and
it's been like it's been something
that's probably kept me going outside of
rugby
um for a decent bit was was cooking
something you're always passionate about
or did you
sort of stumble across it i kind of saw
was stumbled upon it really i think
like it made us kind of be creative like
we both love food and we both
love cooking and it's kind of just by
something we were doing all the time and
we love kind of coming up with new
recipes
trying new things figuring out how it
fit in our diet and um
yeah i think because we were kind of
forced to like do it and put put content
out there it kind of brought the best
out of us in cooking and in kind of
learning nutrition stuff
is that what you're looking to do now
now that you're finished you're looking
to sort of put all your energy into that
um yeah funnily enough it's not actually
i kind of i had this
like obviously it was such a good thing
for us and like we love doing it and
like i said we were kind of qualified
nutrition coaches but i think like
through that process i realized like the
thing that i liked most about it was
kind of like talking to people about
like
their stuff and how they thought about
things and how they like approached
obviously like nutrition was the kind of
thing we were talking about
but people would speak to us about
what they were stressed about issues in
their like difficulties they're going
through in their life and
why they're eating a certain way or why
they wanted to
gain weight or lose weight and i was
kind of i found myself like far more
interested in that than actually
kind of helping them along the kind of
actual nutrition
um and alongside kind of working in
rugby and
having access to psychologists i'm
actually um going to go study psychology
after this so i'm kind of going back to
back to being a student again
so yeah it's something that i've that i
thought about and i was like
you know what this is actually kind of
what i wanted to do like long term
um and like you said it's it's gonna
come at a good time though i'm gonna
have to go back to uni and kind of give
it another crack
so yeah that's that's the plan at the
moment really how many years have you
got to do
at uni yeah so it's a master so i'm
gonna it's basically a one year masters
i've already got an undergrad
and i did alongside the rugby so yeah so
it's basically i'm going to do it two
years part-time
yeah and then like i said i'm in the one
of the the retired players so i'm going
to find some work outside of that
but yeah psychology is the thing i want
to go into uh
kind of long term cool and what's a
dream what's a dream job for you
i'll be honest i don't i don't really
know i think i'd love to work in sport
again
like i see the the work the sports
psychologists do and i think that's sick
and i think
while i kind of want to distance a
little bit from rugby like being
being part of the team and being
involved in in boys
i mean like he knows where he plays
everyone's living their dream and just
being in that environment is so
so cool and so interesting so
i think that's what i'll go to long term
like i've got like a real interest and
there's there's like a
company i'm gonna get involved with
hopefully that kind of do leadership and
like resilience and like kind of mental
skills coaching for children and kind of
young people
yeah um and that's like i find that like
really interesting because obviously
if you can do that at that age then it
helps people like i said when they they
get older and
like [ __ ] hits the fan stuff like this i
guess like if i'd had that
um when i was kind of like 13 14 who
knows
how i'd be able to deal with stuff but i
think that's um that's pretty cool
so i'm kind of going to go down that
road and i mean like you might know at
the moment
i think once you come out rugby it's
always been the kind of like linear this
is where i want to go
and at the moment i'm kind of in that
period of like gotta figure stuff out
and kind of just
enjoy the ride and see what happens
really which i've could have never had
to do
but hopefully hopefully it works out
like that mate that's exciting stuff and
you'll be an
absolute wizard at whatever you choose
but mate what a
what a career what a half career and or
whatever what a start of a new career i
guess
mate what a journey it's been but anyway
we've gone to our instagram
as always for some questions and you
have come up with
plenty mainly from one person but there
is a few others
in here as well first question are you
worried that you'll have some ongoing
concussion issues
uh yeah i am a bit worried um it's uh
i like we mentioned about the guys going
through that moment like
i am a bit worried about that but i
think my rugby career could have come to
an end anyway like i could have had
i could have ruined my knee like
obviously like our good mate mike
he had a pretty a very awful hamstring
injury that sadly finished his career
like that could affect you in lots and
lots of different ways like
like my dad like could never throw
because the shoulder was so [ __ ] from
rugby so like
i am obviously worried but i understand
but like i think we're looked after in a
way that hopefully
i shouldn't have two kind of negative
effects down the future so i am a little
bit worried but like i
i understand that's kind of that's part
part of what we did
fair enough okay next question is three
weeks of footy
after a head knock long enough even if
you have no symptoms
oh um i uh
i'm probably not the person to ask but
to be perfectly honest um but i'll give
i'll give my
i'll give my opinion anyway um i got i
got told a little a while ago by one of
the
the specialists that he said that he
worried for how quickly people got back
after having no symptoms um
so i i just think you've got to be like
you've got to have a
real responsibility for yourself because
you might have had no real symptoms for
a lip for for three weeks let's say
but everyone kind of knows the feeling
when you don't feel quite right when
you're playing back or like like i
remember getting back and i like i felt
fine but i could not take a high ball to
save my life i just couldn't see the
ball
and so i was like either i just suck at
this or there's something still not on
so um which i do i do some
eyeballs i think that's a bad example
but um yeah i think you gotta
you gotta really know like yourself so i
think it's on you on like the player
i know it's difficult when you're
pressured to get back into a sport
and when it's like this is the time it
takes you should be fine by now but
when it when it comes to your head like
i think you do have to take a massive
personal responsibility
to be like am i okay am i right and if
you're not comfortable for whatever
reason
just just take more time i think that's
what i'd say that's good advice because
it's the worst thing about concussion
everyone always asks oh when are you
going to be back
and how you feeling have you got a
headache and all this sort of stuff it's
constant questions about it
and you start overthinking it and you
think am i sweet
i don't quite feel right that sort of
feeling that you feel like i could play
if i needed to sort of thing and that's
where you start getting
so far in your head that you start
overthinking at a
yeah it's so difficult and like i mean
we've we've both been there before like
i even had it when i'd
i'd come back i'd made my decision and
i was like making up stories because
obviously i came back in and like the
two days before i told everyone irish
like
everyone's kind of like oh how's it
going how you feeling when you're gonna
be back exactly that
yeah and i obviously knew that i was
gonna retire so i was had to like just
make up stuff because i just kind of fun
being a weird way
i was telling one person that i was
gonna like take
two weeks one person i'd be back this
week i don't know i don't know but yeah
it is difficult when you get that
bombardment there is pressure to be back
um
and like i said with the concussion
sometimes like you don't know if you
find you but like
i've got no idea i feel a bit weird but
it's been two weeks i should be fine
it's um it's a difficult one
sure is okay oh this is one interesting
one
for some um what are the questions asked
when you get sent off for an hia
you'll know these back the front yeah i
could just
just run you through one now jeffy we'll
do a bit of a role play
you um yeah it's uh i literally this is
so one of them there's a few
um they lit they read you a list of like
10 words out
there by by now every player has
memorized
yeah so they read these 10 words out and
you just like list them off like however
[ __ ] you feel
um so you do that they ask you if you
like numbers they ask you to repeat
numbers and reverse order
they always ask you to say the months of
the year in
reverse order but like i've got no
reason to say
the months of the year in normal order
than out so i genuinely think i'm far
better the other way around for my my
years of his
so they do that um they there's a few
balance tests
so you stand on one foot you stand on
two feet eyes closed
um so there's a few bits and bobs like
that and
yeah and then you basically got ten
minutes to pass it um
and if you're no good for any of those
things they pull you off which i think
i think is pretty good so yeah as most
probably players know by now
it's uh you can kind of memorize it you
can kind of get your way through it so
uh
dabble carpet
yeah bubble carpet apple saddle i'll
keep going
oh that's good stuff okay
what did you put in your will in my will
oh my god right i get what this is now
i had a bit of a shocker
oh mate i was like what was that though
i get what he's all about now
i basically had is like i mean the best
part of like a lot of being in rugby
club is like the socials where
everyone's getting a good piss up
together
yeah and uh i still maintain to this day
so there's one where we had to dress
where where you're from
and where a few of us are from is this
like a county in england called
berkshire which is kind of famous for
its kind of
like shooting like clay pigeon shooting
kind of like
quite like posh and kind of wear lots of
tweed and so a few of us rocked up
wearing tweed and we took like pipes
and um we'd had the social obviously
everyone was getting
getting blitzed and stuff and we were
smoking these pipes and i've got asthma
and i've never smoked a pipe in my life
before
so when it comes time and we're going
home i start having like an asthma
attack
and i ever obviously thought i was just
steaming so i would have a bit of a
shocker and so we get
home to the one of the lads houses and
i'm like lying on the sofa like
lads i can't breathe i can't really
swear god
and um i felt so bad and so i'm
literally like lying like
i've basically taken all my clothes off
at this point so i'm kind of lying kind
of wheezing
on the side of this sofa and um
and i'm glad to like they obviously kind
of already taken it seriously because
they're like
he's just he's just pissed yeah and so
he's like do you want to record an
ambulance i was like yes please
like i'm really kind of emotional by
this point and i'm so emotional at this
point that i think i'm like
done i'm like like in my head this is it
and so i asked matt williams to
basically give me his phone so i could
write down
my last will which is just as like
he's still got it i have no idea what's
on it i don't know what's on my will
jacob
um and but it's on matt's phone he's
like it's
that one thing that he's holding over me
for the rest of my life
um and the sad thing is that the story
finishes with the ambulance rocking up i
felt so bad for wasting their time
and they got there and they they walked
in and they just go you had a few drinks
have you
and i'm like yeah and they go because
obviously worried i've got alcohol
poisoning or something
and they turned they turned to matt and
they're like how much
he had to drink tonight and max looks
then like he kind of looks to the side
and he's like
i think he's probably had four or five
pints of beer
and as they just look at him they're
like four or five pints of beer and
you've called the ambulance here like
what are you doing i like a complete
charm so yeah i was obviously absolutely
fine in the end
but uh that's good hey williams he's got
my last
absolute shocker oh snake he's got a
mega memory that guy
great question he does yeah such a good
question
okay now this question's coming a few
times uh three or four people have sent
this one and
sort of can you sing a song because
obviously you
you're known for a pretty gun voice
we've had a few guys on the podcast
already angus tarvel
sun creed uh jeremy thrush adele
be good to get a uk version of one of
your favorite songs i
i hear you i hear you've got a really
good voice
jimmy i think it could speak to how bad
my voice is i can't do it for you i i
just can't
the boys like know that like i love
white tiger so like there's a song
called white tiger
that's what they want i think okay
ah right i'm gonna compose my second
voice yeah
try still close to myself
that's as much as i'll do it so i'm not
doing any more than that
it was actually unbelievable hey they
weren't
wrong don't lie to me it was impressive
like genuinely every time i'm like a
proper i love like
i'm i'm i'm that guy like in the car
like i love singing yeah but i've just
been berated by my friends over time for
having a terrible voice
so i just like i'm just like i won't do
it i'm just scarred by the years of
abuse
so uh that was cool i was expecting a
lot less
quality okay
what happened when you went to the skate
park
i um one of my locked down hobbies was
like learning to skateboard
and um i obviously have got like a good
history with injury so i'm kind of one
of those clumsy people that gets hurt
and um i was like skating around and
everyone's kind of taking a piss they're
like what are you doing like you're
having a mid-life crisis here
and it's two days before a game and um
i'm kind of just like skating to get my
hair cut or whatever so like
down where like in sunbury there's like
a skate park on the round about where
there's like the barbers and stuff
so i'm like skating past and like i'm
like oh i'm not going to go to like a
skate park i'm just going to kind of
skate around because i don't want to
hurt myself while i'm playing rugby yeah
and um i just like i looked there as i
was just getting past it i was like yeah
there's no one there like normally it's
really full like
like i was like oh i'll give it a crack
like never been anywhere near one before
and so i just like there's obviously
like a big slope going like this big
bowl and i'm just like got to the top of
it and jump to my board
and generally had like as i'm going down
quick wobble like properly hit myself
like i fell off my board like
flew into the air and i've literally got
like
like proper like comedic like slits on
my ass
and then just like hit my like ass on
the floor and then like twatted my face
like just on the concrete and so i'm
like lying there on the floor like two
days before a game like we've literally
just got the team run the next day
and i'm lying on the phone i'm like i'll
just knock myself out like
i'm absolutely fine so i just obviously
i literally just lay on the floor for
probably about
five minutes just sitting there like
what have i done i'm an absolute idiot
i don't feel like i've rocked up the
next day to do the team run and like it
actually kind of hurt my hip a bit so i
was like
running around boys are like like what
are you doing are you okay
i was like yep absolutely fine don't
worry about it um
so like next day and like i'm absolutely
fine and like get through the game
but um it's just like i i said to myself
after that i was like i'm never going to
skateboard
ever again
people like that but yeah
yeah oh man i was properly sketched out
it's just like a worst nightmare oh
classic good yarns okay
what's your family kit's name and why
[Laughter]
i'm happy this has come out now because
the
the man in question knows so oh this is
just a horrible story i had
i had a family cat when i was younger
right and i kind of grew up in the area
ever like a few of the lives that we
grew up here were always kind of london
irish fans or whatever
and um when i was probably i must have
been like
probably 12 like 12 my sister was 14 and
we got we got a cat for the first time
my family mum
mum got a cat and we kind of think about
names
and my sister goes uh oh this is um
she's like oh that that team you you're
playing for they're uh they've got
another player called topsy
um as in topsy yojo like the the kind of
the record holder for
do you know this by the way the legion
no i don't know this right
yeah so topsy so daisy was like yeah
we'll call it topsy
and so my cat's called topsy like go
live the next kind of
six years of my life with my family cat
as you do
um i never really thought at that time
that i ended up playing with him
and so he um obviously we get and like i
can't remember like a an eye out or
something
like one of my like friends in the
academy found out in my first year
that my cat was called topsy and
obviously like topsy's at the club like
this club legend is still playing
and so like i'm just like mortified that
someone knows and that someone's going
to tell him
so i've got i've genuinely got like
i've basically like like made everyone
swear they'd never tell him because i
was so embarrassed that my cats could
toxic and um literally like whole career
like ended up being like good mates to
them like he's kind of like obviously a
club legend retired a few years ago
like he never found out never found out
and
he actually lives really near me now so
we both live in sunbury and so he
literally lives over the road so like we
go to the same corner shop so bump into
each other every night every night again
like talk about stuff or whatever
and my missus um who
had never met him was like we were going
to the shop to get something and tops is
there like we have a bit of a chat and
i'm like oh
they hadn't met so i was like oh melanie
this is topsy yeah
and they're already just like without
saying hi to him obviously she said hi
but she looks at me and she goes
that that's the one i was like what'd
you mean she was like that's the guy you
named your caster
like straight to his face but i'm
there's like
i will kill you i'm just like i can't
believe it got to this point
seven years down the line when i first
met him and like melanie is the person
to just say just out like like oh that's
the guy you know
you can't after and he obviously is just
like what the [ __ ]
like i had no idea so that was that was
a pretty
i was a bit of a shocker but um yeah so
that was good
are you still together
we're still together yeah and and topsy
still talks to me as well so uh
so everyone everyone lived happy ever
after yeah like it's just one of those
things that you're so embarrassed about
as a kid
and then i was like he's a grown man now
like seven years after i first met him
and the longer you lift it up the
weirder it got
the weirder it got and like at this
point like i've stopped playing with him
i've been two years after
i just never found out honestly
so embarrassing oh good stuff
okay can you do a kickflip um
i cannot do a kickflip i unfortunately
cannot do a kickflip
i'm like i've said about my kind of
issue at the skate park like
i've just a bit like i still i still
like three people i love skating but
like i just like skate around
and like i basically have these like
kids like
that i know this is him from jacob as
well though
i um i like had like
so i like i will like skate around
sunbury or whatever just like
it's kind of like easy to get around
whatever but obviously like there's
loads of schools around
and like i've had a i've had a like a
kid
come up to me as in like just like
they're like loads of kids girlfriend
from school and they're like
like everyone like shouts like can you
do a kickflip um
and i'm like no i can't do a kickflip
and he's just like
you [ __ ] loser and then just starts
like shouting at me because i can't do a
kick clip
i'm sitting there like on my way home
from training whatever getting abused by
this like 10 year old kid
that can't do a kick flip like yeah
pretty horrendous
oh good stuff you must be out of doing
ollie though
genuinely i've just kind of learned i've
done a couple mate
um but this is the thing like everyone
says like oh yeah i like skateboarding
and everyone's like could you do that
and i'm like no
no could you do that like no just like
right there
cruising around like but everyone's like
everyone's kind of like
everybody's playing with me it's like
seeing the size of my feet i've got like
clown like size like 12 and a half feet
and so like i was just never meant to
like be skillful with them like even now
to be fair like
the boys turn around i'm like one of
those guys that like falls over his own
feet so like people were sending around
videos like literally in training the
other day
like no one around me just like they're
like jogging backwards getting
positioned and just like tripping over
and just like properly stacking it so
i still do that so it keeps flips away
off of me
yeah fair enough okay that goes back to
this one
is it true that london irish had to get
an excavator to replace your divots
after each kickoff
yes they did i had uh this one's from
this one's yeah
i actually told i told someone this the
other day i had um
so one of these feet this uh this foot
injury that i was telling you about so
obviously i've had like
operational weight is my kicking foot my
right foot yeah and um
so it's taking me like operation it's
been about seven months
since since i did it and kind of my feet
and obviously i've come back and done a
bit of kicking and i was back in
training it's like my first day in
training
after seven months out and um i've
literally
like i've been kind of like thinking
about this moment i'm like wrong i'm
gonna have to do a kick off for the
start of training
um and to be fair like even now i still
get a bit sketchy about doing kickoff
because everyone's there watching you
you're like just kick it to the pod i
just want to catch it
it's not a big deal and um so it's my
first day back in trading
and i'm kind of standing there like
shaking with the ball and kivo's like
don't kick the floor boris and i'm like
look up and i'm like oh god here we go
so i've like gone through like dropped
the ball and as i've gone to kick it
i've hit the ball j i've hit the floor
genuinely about that far behind the ball
like absolutely belted the floor just
like
topped the ball like 10 yards as it
rolls forward and sort of picks it up
and everyone's like people are just
screaming at me i'm genuinely like this
is my first kick back in training and
i'm like i've broken my foot again
i've taken such a big deal out of the
pitch that my foot's gone i'm done
i'm sitting there just like what has
happened yeah kivo just got
well and truly in my head that day i
think i remember
that oh he was good at that sort of
stuff
i was just like if anyone else had said
it i probably would have been like uh
yeah funny but i was just like
oh no it's gonna happen
yeah honestly horrendous two more
questions
did you get the nickname boris yeah i
mean to be fair if you've listened to
like an hour of this podcast you
probably don't find out i'm just like
i had this thing when i was coming
through the academy of like i would just
tell like
i'm the guy who like tells like really
just boring facts like i'll just say to
be like oh i found something else today
and it's just like no one cares like no
one cares
which is fair enough and then so i had a
i had a mate in the academy ollie adams
he was just like kind of like south
london like bit of a geezer
and um i like told him something and he
was like mate
you are so boring like just stop telling
me these nothing stories
and he was after a while he said i felt
bad for calling you boring all the time
so i thought i'd just give you a boy a
name
so i'll call you boris and and
thankfully it's not related to boris
johnson forever in the uk i'm
i'm not like boris johnson so it's not
to do with that but um
he literally and it was one of those you
know when you get a nickname like like
snake did
yeah and you just fight it and you just
fight it and you fight it and then
everyone loves it and like
it got to the point where no one knew
particularly why i was called boris but
the fact that i hated it so much so
everyone kind of loved it like
i agreed to kind of love it it was kind
of a bit of me and
um yeah obviously like i still get
called it and stuff so um
i like it now but yeah it came out from
molly just uh just give me a bit of
stick basically
i had no idea that was the background of
that that's that's a good yarn
okay last question one piece of advice
you'd give a young
rugby player coming through the grades
yeah
i mean i think i mentioned it earlier
and it's when i kind of look back and
i was talking to you about those kind of
early years of my career i think
just like learning to be like build like
good relationships with people around
you like
you mentioned like obviously like you
and like kibbo you mentioned and
i look to you guys and kind of just the
ability to like just like connect with
people
and have a a good laugh obviously while
you're playing i know there's times
where you take stuff seriously but
just build like is like invest in the
relationships around you like take care
of your mates like
have a really good time with them and
like enjoy kind of coming through or
just enjoy playing rugby
with your mates in the group of people
that you have because
like like you'll know when you look back
you're like i'm kind of happy at the
moment like
like if people ask me about like the
best times in my career
like the first thing i'm probably gonna
say is it's not like it was this way
noise this thing that we won like wow
that's great but it's like it's
kind of the cool memories the like the
fun you have like
the times you're like pissing around
with your mates like building like
really good relationships or like
it's obviously like i think it's a skill
that will make you better rugby but also
you'll like enjoy your time you'll enjoy
what you're doing and you'll have
brilliant people around you and i think
um i think that's the thing that i would
say to young rugby players don't get too
hung up on
being just rugby rugby rugby just like
have good relationships around that and
really enjoy your time oh man how good
that advice
what a way to finish the podcast some of
the greatest advice we've had on yet
but anyway mate really appreciate you
coming on the podcast gutted to hear
that you've
had to retire but i'm stoked to hear
that you're
you're still feeling well you're not
going to be suffering as you go forward
and really looking forward to seeing
what is next for you
i'm excited to see what team you end up
being their sports psych
obviously going to be a gun edit the way
you always thought about the game and
the way you spoke about
um just things in general always
interest me and you'll be an absolute
guru and looking forward to following
your journey in that space but really
appreciate you coming on the podcast and
giving up your time
i really appreciate jimmy was good fun
he was good good to catch up again mate
yeah likewise
[Music]
[Music]
you